etiquette lessons and dance rehearsals
and
i mean it was it was kind of crazy
bridgerton may look
picture-perfect but it wasn't always
smooth sailing for the cast
like any shonda rhimes show the
production was meticulous with details
and bringing the best possible show to
our screens
how did one of the cast members get
badly injured by a prop on set
we are taking a look at all the
struggles the cast face during filming
from politics to intimacy
to exhausting training the please
after you how did the cast manage to
look like they were plucked right out of
the regency era
weeks of intensive training in a kind of
bridgerton boot camp
not only did the cast have to speak and
behave as if they were living in another
era they also had to elevate everything
so they could convincingly portray the
high-class characters
phoebe denver had the most training as
daphne bridgerton
she found herself quite overwhelmed with
the intensive schedule in her six weeks
of prep prior to filming
while the actress has been in the
business for a long time it didn't
prepare her for the strenuous schedule
that included horse riding lessons
dance classes piano lessons etiquette
lessons and
intimacy training but more on that later
i mean it was it was kind of crazy i
think we're all ready to
to get on the marriage mart now the
women in the cast had to appear as if
they were real debutants
so they all went through etiquette
training and also had to work that much
harder to stay in character
what's fascinating is that all of this
training was a typical part of people's
lives in that era
while the actors didn't have to worry
too much about bringing accurate accents
to the screen since most of them were
from the uk
there was enormous pressure to bring the
posh and proper way of speaking to their
performances
if any of the actors slipped up and
sounded as if they weren't living in the
regency era
the scene had to be done all over again
that's a cut good
if the actors didn't sit eat or even
walk
as their high class characters more
takes had to be done
it wasn't just the women who had a lot
of training though
reggae jean page had a 5 a.m wake-up
call followed by intensive physical
training to prepare for the role
and that was just the beginning of his
day he had to be on set
and ready to go for a grueling day of
filming so
loads of training um but also there was
some of the most fun days that we had on
set
he may have looked incredibly natural on
a horse but
this was actually a big struggle for
paige who didn't have that much
experience with horses
the difficulty of safely and confidently
riding the horses was of course
important but on top of that they needed
to act at the same time
of course some of the most incredible
scenes are the dance sequences
for which the entire cast had to
rehearse extensively in order to execute
the scenes perfectly
because it is period dancing but it's
like with a slight darker
sexy tone when we think of bridgerton
one word that definitely comes to mind
is steamy
reggae jean page and phoebe denver had a
whole lot of sensual and intimate scenes
that were filmed with a whole crew
around them
one of the first scenes they filmed was
part of their honeymoon sequence
extreme intimacy fortunately by this
point
paige and denver had spent so much time
together prepping it was easier for them
to perform the steamy scenes because
they developed a relationship of their
own
we've had an intimacy coach which i've
never had before in a job
part of the training involved their
intimacy coordinator who made sure
all the intimate scenes were rehearsed
and choreographed meticulously to keep
filming professional
and comfortable but i don't think it was
that awkward to begin
with we were lucky enough to have a lot
of preparation with many period dramas
on tv
viewers will notice the cast is
typically white
making bridgerton a huge leap from that
colorblind casting has been a big topic
of conversation
though the casting had a lot of thought
behind it it may be a surprise to see
queen charlotte as a black woman
but the fact is it is believed that she
was actually of african descent
the show does an exemplary job of
inclusivity and putting incredible
actors of color in leading roles
though there is some difficulty because
there is an erasure of the struggles
these minority groups actually went
through at the time
while there may be a bit of compromising
the history it feels right that today
our tv screens look as diverse as our
world
yet you know what people of color
existed in this country right back to
roman times
the clothing worn in bridgerton is
incredible and the sheer
quantity is impressive the actors
collectively wore
around 7 500 different costumes in the
first season
the scenes on screen of the women having
their corsets tightened shows just some
of the struggle the cast had with their
outfits
keep in mind the lavish costumes were
also
very heavy and therefore hot add lights
for filming and group dance sequences
the cast often grew extremely warm and
the restrictive clothing didn't leave
much room for comfort
while the actors didn't always have to
wear corsets as a base
their complex dresses made sitting
walking and
especially horseback riding that much
more complicated
the clothing may look beautiful but it
wasn't the most comfortable to wear for
hours on
end actress nichola coughlin had one of
the more tragic outfit incidents when
she
tripped as a result of not having enough
control or balance in her corset and
heels
it not only negatively affected her as
she had a parasol in her hand which
wound up injuring the hand of a fellow
actor
i know there's some kind of corsetry
acting awards but i would like one
for doing a full jig in this it wasn't
easy showbiz
is not easy and the work it takes to
bring a hit like bridgerton to life is
evident
knowing all the work that went into the
intimate scenes how do you feel about
them now
what about knowing the struggle all the
actors and corsets faced
let us know what you think in the
comments if you enjoyed
give us a like and make sure to
subscribe to the things